and welcome to hannity all right
democrats they want this to be january 6
week but they will not give you the full
story and by the way there is a lot of
context a lot of texture a lot of things
they will not be telling you about and
tonight we're going to give you the
vital information about what really
happened on january 6th what happened on
january 4th we'll tell you why the
democrats are not serious about
preventing something like this from ever
happening again just like they ignored
the riots in 2020. they're mostly
peaceful oh okay tell that to the
thousands of injured cops the dozens of
dead americans and the billions of
property damage that people suffered
democrats will purposefully omit details
about what happened on the sixth and
before the 6th but we will give you
those details that you likely never
heard before and we have special guests
that will confirm all of this for you
people involved in all of this but first
joe biden is finally back from the beach
wow and he is seething with rage tonight
not because of record high gas prices
which have now more than doubled in just
18 months under his watch he's not
seething because the american people are
suffering from backbreaking of what
42-year record high of inflation and
looming stagflation and a
looming recession not because the border
crisis which is getting worse every day
oh and by the way as we speak the
biggest caravan to date is now
approaching our southern border so
buckle up and let's not forget that joe
has simply turned the page on our fellow
americans trapped in afghanistan we'll
hit the number 300 this week if you're
counting like we are it is day 296 since
joe abandoned our fellow americans
behind enemy lines and even confirmed
what two weeks ago by wink and tony
blinken now sadly as we speak joe biden
is seemingly unconcerned with any of
these serious crises and he's doing
nothing to resolve any of them instead
biden is now throwing a pity party for
himself because he's polling lower than
donald trump and many are now beginning
to compare him to jimmy carter or even
worse now with the midterms now fast
approaching democrats have absolutely
nothing constructive to run on nothing
their president their policies their
radical green new deal agenda all are
massive failures so democrats they are
employing what is a desperate
multi-prong political strategy for the
upcoming election january 6 is a part of
it but first they're planning to scare
you the voters with a heavy dose of
hysteria surrounding abortion now if roe
v wade is ultimately overturned by the
supreme court we have every indication
that will happen democrats will go out
there and campaign that a woman's right
to choose has been abolished in america
abortions are illegal and republicans
aren't to blame they will evoke coat
hangers and back alley abortions they
will predict widespread suffering and
despair against for women they will
claim that america as we now know it is
over
none of that will be true abortion is
not an enumerated right in our
constitution but if roe is overturned as
it appears it may be it will be
regulated by individual states per the
10th amendment to the constitution in
other words almost all u.s states will
continue to allow abortion with very
liberal states like california etc
likely allowing abortion up until the
moment of birth which we would call on
this program infanticide
now the second prong of the democratic
election strategy for the midterms well
that surrounds guns in the second
amendment as we speak democrats are
vilifying law-abiding gun owners they're
after gun manufacturers they're after
the nra they're vowing to restrict your
second amendment rights this too as a
strategy i predict will fail and don't
forget according to the cdc there are up
to 2.5 million defensive gun uses each
year in other words they save lives for
example over the weekend a west virginia
woman heroically shot and killed a
gunman who was firing into a graduation
party at an apartment complex and she is
now being credited with saving perhaps
20 to 30 lives but of course the media
mob the democrats they'll never talk
about or report that incident if
democrats get their way only the
criminals who don't care about laws will
have access to the firearms and we will
all be defenseless ultimately the
fear-mongering surrounding guns is a
little more than a political ploy and
when you have nothing else to talk about
in a midterm election year and all your
policies have failed well i guess you
know it's a hail mary for them now if
democrats really cared about gun control
they would call on the president's own
son yeah hunter biden to be prosecuted
hunter reportedly lied on his background
check about his rampant drug use in
order to purchase a firearm that would
be a felony then get this hunter's gun
was eventually thrown away in a grocery
store dumpster across from a high school
for reasons nobody seems to know and now
we have pictures that have surfaced
today showing hunter waving around a
semi-automatic handgun while naked
according to the new york post they're
saying possibly with a hooker we can't
confirm that part but just imagine if
his last name was hunter trump
what the reaction in the media and what
the reaction from the democrats would be
but the bidens want to lecture us on
responsible gun ownership uh does that
look like responsible gun ownership to
you joe
should your son go to jail or maybe i'll
say it in a way that you'll understand
for god's sakes joe can't you do
something about your own son
and this brings us now to the third
prong of the democrats election strategy
which as you can probably guess is
january 6 2021.
now they have this big hearing except
for thursday
you will not hear the real story of
january 6 anywhere i don't think except
here and you definitely won't hear from
house democrats or the two republicans
that are really democrats on the
committee because remember they kicked
off jim jordan and jim banks they would
have asked questions like we have been
asking and they would have gotten to the
truth but without a doubt
their conduct surrounding that fateful
day is not this is pure political
theater and right on cue this thursday
night the sham january 6 committee will
be holding their big prime time show
hearing a full-on hollywood multimedia
extravaganza with of course hollywood
creative license to embellish omit as
desired and they've even procured
professional fake news production help
from a former abc executive of oh good
morning america nightline they've gone
all out for this and it turns out this
is the same executive who reportedly
spiked the abc news report that would
have exposed jeffrey epstein many years
ago we'll have more on that later in the
program
now this upcoming hearing on thursday
aims to do one thing and that is excite
their democratic base vilify donald
trump and all of his supporters yet
again in other words uh it's like a
third impeachment and just last week
trump adviser peter navarro he was
thrown in handcuffs and leg shackles at
an airport for refusing to participate
in the sham hearing he was allegedly
thrown in the same jail cell used for
reagan's assassin john hinckley now this
after being charged with two misdemeanor
process crimes for not cooperating with
house democrats navarro
would have gladly and this is the normal
course of business for something not
that serious he would have they would
have called his lawyer say turn yourself
in at this location at 8 a.m and he
would have done it easily posted bail as
is customary with minor offenses such as
the one he's being charged with but he
was never given that opportunity instead
democrats use law enforcement as a
political weapon to intimidate and
embarrass navarro like they did with
manafort and roger stone and george
papadopoulos and so many others now
there's no respect for our federal
government or no aspect of it that
democrats will not weaponize now this
upcoming made for tv you know fully
produced congressional hearing is no
exception this is where it gets
interesting despite all the hysteria the
truth is clear and if the committee had
any real intention of getting to the
truth and preventing this from ever
happening again which should be their
goal i condemn this in real time on my
radio show we condemned it right here on
this program that night like we
condemned all the riots in the summer of
2020 that were not mostly peaceful now
they would not be turning to this into
another hoax impeachment of course
they've had a predetermined outcome
sadly from the beginning knowing the
dangers associated with large protests
it turns out that donald trump approved
up to 20 000 national guard troops that
would bolster the capital well in
advance of the rally on january 6th he
did it on january 4th my prediction is
is that they will lie by omission the
committee will keep that critical fact
out of the circus presentation that they
you know are creating as we speak their
hollywood show that they're going to put
on they won't focus on once the
president as required by law signed off
on up to 20 000 troops being called up
that was his role then the jurisdiction
went to nancy pelosi who's in charge of
security for the house along with the
sergeant of arms and the d.c mayor
bowser who refused to call up the guard
again
that that is their call as required by
law donald trump did his part and if
donald trump really wanted this breach
of the capital why would he have
authorized up to 20 000 national guard
troops now there are multiple documents
and statements to back all this up and
the january 6 committee has all of this
but they won't be including it on
thursday by the way that would include
this letter from mayor bowser declining
national guard support prior to january
6 these documents from a recent
inspector general's report that details
how trump's department of defense
planned for january 6 and they planned
appropriately and they responded for
calls for assistance appropriately and
they did not delay or obstruct the
response to the january 6 riot now we
also reached out to biden's defense
secretary mark milley he was in a high
level role at the dod during january 6.
he's yet to provide us with a comment
they said they wouldn't get back to us
tonight hopefully we will be able to
report tomorrow what their answer is but
don't forget right here on this program
the dod
chief of staff department of defense
chief of staff cash patel along with the
acting department of defense secretary
chris miller they will join us in a
minute along with the white house chief
of staff mark meadows and president
trump himself four of the five people in
the room on january 4th
all of them have confirmed what we know
to be true that donald trump did request
and as required by law approved and
authorized up to 20 000 guard troops to
be called up by pelosi and bowser should
they need them and want them he saw this
as a potential
a potentially dangerous situation why
wouldn't he after coming off the riots
of the summer of 2020 take a look
did you authorize calling up the guard
and then it became
at the chain of command went to nancy
pelosi and to the mayor of d.c muriel
bowser did you as required by law
authorize that
100 percent and attested to by many
people and they turned it down
nancy pelosi turned it down mayor
bowser's written refusal the
communications between the leader of the
capitol police and their chain of
command to the dod refusing our request
to allow national guardsmen and women to
stage on january 4 and 5 before january
6. did you both ask for the national
guard to be called up
without a doubt sean uh we've made that
very clear not just once but on numerous
occasions we wanted to make sure that
there was plenty of national guard on
the ready
in case there was some kind of violence
i had a meeting with president trump on
the 3rd of january concerning some
international threats and at the very
end he asked if there were any requests
for national guard support what was the
president's response to you
with regard to the requests made by
mayor bowser
fill it and do whatever was necessary to
protect the
uh demonstrators
now kash patel and the former acting
defense secretary chris miller will join
us in a second now of course none of
what you just saw
i i predict will be played by the
january 6 committee they don't care
about the truth sadly they're not even
looking for ways to better secure the
capital and protect our elected leaders
which we must do
they're just smearing trump again and
again and again and attempting to cement
their power in d.c according to reports
we have democrat
jamie raskin now wants to use the
january 6 committee to abolish the
electoral college so major population
centers new york and california and new
jersey and illinois
they can rule the country with an iron
fist in perpetuity now clearly if you're
actually interested in the truth about
january 6 and not just using it as a
political weapon and you want to protect
all elected officials uh you're better
off watching this program hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else